So let's say we have a slightly more complicated grammar.
T is our start symbol; it goes to (p Q r)
or (p Q s), so there are two strings in this grammar.
It will 100 percent increase, over the previous grammar--
(p Q r) and (p Q s) are both there--
and the input is: (P q r)--wow, that's really lucky!
That's one of the strings in the grammar.
It's almost as if we planned these things in advance.
So now we'll give you a chance to try this out.
I have written down, here,
five possible facts about the parsing chart
for this grammar, on this 3-token input.
Chart[1] has this, chart[1] has that.
This is an element of chart[1], this is an element of chart[2].
And what I'd like you to do in this multiple multiple choice quiz
is check all of the boxes that are correct.
So if we do see: big (Q) goes to little (q) dot,
from 1 in chart[2], check this box.
Check all the boxes that apply.